roger federer has given us some of the
most thrilling moments we've seen in
tennis
[Applause]
but at 41 the swiss star has finally
decided to call it quits
the past three years have presented me
with challenges in the form of injuries
and surgeries but i also know my body's
capacities and limits and its message to
me lately has been clear
chinese has treated me more generously
than i ever would have dreamt and now i
must recognize when it is time to end my
competitive career
[Laughter]
next week's laver cup in london will be
federer's final atp event and he won't
play any more grand slams it's the knee
issue all over again when it comes to
the grind of the regular tour his body
is not being able to stand up to that i
think we could all see it coming but it
still comes as a shock and a surprise
federer's first of 20 grand slam titles
came at wimbledon in 2003 where he
instantly became a crowd favorite people
came
from basel and home and so nice you know
to share this moment
and
thanks to everybody it's great
congratulations roger federer
a total of 103 atp titles followed in a
career that included an incredible 1
251 match wins the swiss maestro spent a
total of 310 weeks as world number one
amassing more than 130 million dollars
in prize money throughout his career i
consider myself one of the most
fortunate people on earth i was given a
special talent to play tennis and i did
it at a level that i never imagined for
much longer than i ever thought possible
some of the matches just to see
how glorious he was on a tennis court
his movement was like a ballet dancer i
mean there's so many
moments with his career and he's just a
really nice guy
federer leaves the game third on the
list of all-time grand slam champions
behind novak djokovic and rafael nadal
i actually do think he's the greatest
roger was the benchmark was the bar for
men's
what a tennis
joanna gazroska al jazeera